fabrice luchini remarquable dans ce film
certains de mes confrères ce matin lors
de la projection du film on applaudit
réflexe rares croyez moi dans la
profession ils ont eu la tentation de
confondre les deux personnages
l'imaginaire casanova et le réel alain
delon quant à l'acteur s'est il
identifié à ce vieux séducteur devenu
humble et fragile tout à coup sa réponse
dans l'entretien qu'il nous a accordé
tout à l'heure l entretien filmé par
georges milan gua et didier thiébaut
savez je crois que dans la vie d'un
homme comme dans la vie d'un acteur il
ya des moments il ya des rencontres qui
arrivent bien et je crois que c'était
peut-être le moment que je rencontre
casanova devant la caméra tenir mme ans
je crois qu'il ya sûrement un phénomène
d'osmose c'est vrai c'est vrai aussi que
j'ai l'âge du personnage on n'est plus
au xviiie siècle bientôt 21e mais quand
même c'est vrai qu'il ya peut-être eu ya
peut-être eu une espèce de mariage comme
ça ou de superposition des deux images
le film d'edouard niermans c'est
intéressant dans la mesure où il ya un
ton fin subtil mais critique sur les
relations humaines sur la comédie
humaine et schmisser l'air oui dit ce
n'est celle du séducteur montèrent
menteur que vous êtes dans le film celle
du prêtre qui jouent au poker
celle des femmes adultères
on va le dire et des hommes lâche oui
mais tout ça je veux dire ça mais que le
roman de schnitzler j'ai dit comédie
humaine on peut dire hypocrisie on peut
dire aussi solitude mais là il ya un
coin est né à nantes par ici et plein de
solitude évidemment mais là c'est un
thème que je connais bien et bon c'est
vrai que je j'aime j'aime vivre dans la
solitude et que casanova dans l'oeuvre
de chenilles de serre et d'un personnage
on ne peut plus solitaire même au milieu
de toutes ces femmes
même au milieu de tous ces succès
féminins plus là où on va le découvrir
ce soir mais c'est une forme de solitude
bien sûr on quitte un instant casanova
rjr aurait pour 21,5 à propos de
solitude et à propos de donc de
communication ou de non communication
vous étiez absent ce matin la conférence
de presse et j'avoue que votre absence a
suscité des remarques des critiques
alors je vais vous dire j'étais absent
simplement pas par sympathie et par
différence vis-à-vis du metteur en scène
et de mes partenaires
du producteur parce que je sais
pardonnez moi c'est pas une fausse
modestie je sais que lorsque j'arrive
dans ce genre de contre ce conférence de
presse jacques à part les microphones
jacquin par les caméras et c'est ce que
je ne voulais pas maintenant ce qu'on
vend 10 est ce qu'on en pense ça m'est
complètement égal et indifférent ce qui
compte c'est ce que je dis moi parce que
c'est la vérité
n'at il pas pu voir vous n'étiez pas là
le film d'ouverture benzi christine avec
michael il m'a dit que c'était un fils
pour le festival de deauville
oui je sais et moi je les styles à leur
nouvel américain
oui c'est ça oui bien sûr pour le oui
c'est ça el jabri l'amérique non alors
dites moi
alors que pensez vous du choix je ne dis
pas du film parce qu'on n'avait pas vu
âme est le choix je ne le critique pas
je ne le juge pas le choix appartient au
délégué général du festival donc je n'ai
pas à me prononcer là dessus
maintenant si je vois le film peut-être
que j'aurai une autre critique à
formuler une critique implicite dans le
festival de deauville c'est clair donc
vous regretter un peu le soin latino
américains c'est ce qui m'a semblé si
vous voulez aller coûte ce matin les
gens avaient l'air un peu déçu en me
disant c'était pas le film qu'on aurait
souhaité voir à l'ouverture d'un
festival de cannes d'abord parce que
c'est quand même il faudrait de temps en
temps que le festival de cannes soit
ouvert par un film français un grand
film français moi personnellement ça me
ferait très plaisir
vous auriez souhaité que ce le fait par
le vôtre mais il en avait été question
mais on ma toujours expliqué que le film
d'ouverture ne peut ne pouvait pas être
en compétition et là on me dit que le
film américain est en combiné j'ai
l'impression que ça change tout le temps
c'est al volo cet entretien je le
rappelle est enregistrée puisque au
moment même de sa diffusion dans le
19/20 vous serez vous êtes si j'ose dire
dans la salle oui du grand palais oui en
train de regarder votre film avec autour
de vous tout le monde pour les membres
du jury
ou est-ce que vous allez ressentir à ce
moment là je ne vais penser qu'à la
sortie c'est à dire je vais penser à
leurs réactions et comment vont ils
sortir ça veut dire vont-ils et mais
vont-ils apprécier
c'est la première fois que je vais le
voir entouré de deux milliers de
personnes dont 75 pour cent pour cent
des professionnels donc la réaction est
très importante pour moi et je vais
penser à leur réaction finale et la
réaction finale vous avez vous la
connaissez déjà à la fin parce qu'il va
se produire applaudissements aux
applaudissements il ya différentes
nuances d'applaudissements et puis aussi
parce que melville appelait parce que
melville appelait la qualité des
silences
j'attache une grande importance à la
qualité des silences pendant la
projection du film vous attendez le prix
d'interprétation
j'attends rien du tout j'attends
simplement que les gens soient
conscients qu'on a fait un beau un grand
film que ce film plaise et fasse le
maximum d'entrées parce que le cinéma a
besoin de ça surtout le cinéma français
pour pouvoir se battre contre le cinéma
américain